extinction rebellion have caused
disruption across the globe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the uk since 2019 more than 50
million pounds has been spent policing
their protests and that's not including
current demonstrations like this it's
fair to say the british government does
not see them as a force for good
[Music]
extinction rebellion claim to be an
environmental campaign group
yet that worthy cause
is undermined by their tactics
politicians wouldn't say that if they
didn't think the public agreed protest
is supposed to be more peaceful and it
just
really angered a lot of people for
unnecessary reasons and of the uk's most
prominent campaigns in 2019 extinction
rebellion were the least popular with
the public
obviously he's going to get coverage and
recognition but on the flip side i think
it's not at least going to know more
people than you know get their point
across yet they were also the most
recognized 57 percent of people polled
knew who extinction rebellion were and
what their campaign was about i mean
i've watched don't tell you what's your
social media i mean i love to get
involved
so has their notoriety led to any
concrete change or just a lot of angry
commuters their cause is noble right
green cannot be enough
but disrupting everyone else's you know
commute or whatever it is then i'm sorry
no it just they lose my support during
the two-week process in 2019 the
campaign was mentioned 70 000 times in
online media
and politicians have certainly taken
notice with extinction rebellion being
mentioned over 200 times in parliament
so have the protesters had any impact on
climate policy
i particularly remember the
extinction rebellion protests in
parliament square
uh which came in the run-up to the
publication of the net zero report i on
my way into parliament several times was
handed leaflets by you know really quite
elderly people um apologizing for the
disruption but explaining
how important they felt
the issues were i know that we're
causing a lot of disruption i really
know that but the disruption that if we
don't do something it's just going to be
such it's going to be catastrophic i
think it struck a lot of people
and a lot of parliamentarians i mean the
amendment to the climate change act was
i think was probably the fastest
response
that the climate change committee had
had ever had to a recommendation um i
think it probably was part of of what
moved things so quickly at that time
extinction rebellion may have cost the
taxpayer 50 million pounds in policing
but they say government action to tackle
climate change could save all of us far
more
the uk national audit office estimates
that for every one pound spent on
protecting communities from flooding
around nine pounds in property damages
and wider impacts can be avoided
academics predict that failure to invest
in climate policy could cost the world
410.4 trillion pounds in the next 200
years
and the uk's independent climate change
advisor warns by 2050 the number of heat
related deaths in the uk could more than
triple to around 7 000 a year
extinction rebellion may be divisive but
they argue the fact we're even talking
about them proves their campaign is
working